Hi, I'm Eric Voss
And Captain Marvel ain't just an origin story
for Captain Marvel,
the newest hero to join the Avengers,
it's also an origin story for Nick Fury and Phil Coulson!
Uncannily deep faked into children,
because this movie ties into the MCU
in so many interesting ways.
Subtle nods to the Guardians of the Galaxy, Avengers, Winter Soldier, even the Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Maybe even saying where the MCU could go beyond Endgame!
So let's re-watch this movie scene-by-scene
break it all down for all the Easter eggs and
film-making details that you might've missed
Spoiler warning, in case you haven't
seen Captain Marvel yet
I will ruin your life.
Let's get started.
OK.  Before this movie even begins,
there's a big Marvel shout-out
In the form of a tribute to the late, great Stan Lee
With this being the first Marvel Studios film release
since his passing.
The studio's title sequence
has replaced the various Avengers
with Stan from his many cameos.
Including:
the FedEX driver in Civil War,
*Stan Lee impression*
Package for Tony Stank
as Hugh Hefner in the first Iron Man,
the Sakaar barber in Ragnarok,
the World War II general in the first Captain America,
and the drunk vet. in Age of Ultron.
Also, the guy on the bus in Doctor Strange.
Tons of others.
It's a touching memorial, but I just love how this reminds us
how Stan is an actual physical person!
Physically many people
throughout this whole movie universe
And despite his departure from our world, his presence still lives on in the cinematic world
The opening frame show us the cryptic dream of
our hero, Carol Danvers (Brie Larsen),
as she tries to piece together her past
A mysterious accident that led to gaining super-natural abilities
It's fitting that this movie using this whole
'fractured memory' device,
because in the comics Captain Marvel's whole history is ridiculously complicated.
Originally, the character was male, a Kree warrior known as Mar-Vell.
I know, it's goofy,
but there already was a Captain Marvel in comics;
the DC hero, who the young Billy Batson turns into
when he says "SHAZAM!"
Over time Marvel was able to stick to the name
'Captain Marvel' for their hero
and DC just started calling their guy 'Shazam'
And it's not at all confusing that
movies for Captain Marvel
and Shazam are released with a month of each other
Anyway Captain Marvel had a female counterpart named Ms. Marvel over the years.
With an interesting wardrobe
And a few decades later,
Captain Marvel was relaunched
as a United States Air Force pilot, Carol Danvers
Who directly took on the Kree powers
and the mantle of 'Captain Marvel'
Which had been a very popular series by comic writer Kelly Sue DeConnick
Here Annet Bening plays the Kree scientist
named Mar-Vell,
who brings Danvers into the fold;
we'll get to her backstory later
Danvers, or as she's known here 'Vers'
from the second half of her last-name
on her severed dog-tag,
Wakes up on the Kree planet of Hala.
The Kree are a race of genetically superior warriors
and they're locked in a perennial war with the Skrull,
a race of shapeshifters
The Kree have shown up in Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
as well as the Guardians of the Galaxy movies
like Ronan the Accuser and Korath are Kree
who show up in both films.
In Captain marvel they're still part of the Kree military
Later on, in Guardians, they'll be extremists
disavowed by the Kree leadership.
But still, the Kree race
has never been cast in a positive light.
"He is slaughtering children.  Families."
"*That* is your business."
"Now, I have other matters to attend to."
"Prick."
Actually, early drafts of the first Guardians of the Galaxy
and of this movie were written by the same screenwriter, Nicole Perlman.
So they do share a sort of DNA
For example, just as they do in the Guardians movies,
every time a new planet or location is introduced,
notice how navigation co-ordinates appear beneath the name of the place.
Vers spars with her mentor, Jude Laws' character
His name wasn't really spoken aloud much,
but it is Yon-Rogg
And that's because Yon-Rogg is Captain Marvel's long-time Kree nemesis in the comics
and we later find out that this guy is a bad guy
As they spar Vers is prevented from powering up fully by this inhibitor ship in her neck
This is similar to the inhibitor that was used on Quake
in Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
A show where a lot of the gadgetry could have been base don Kree technology.
Vers meets with the Kree Supreme Intelligence;
it's an A.I. authority that, in the comics,
takes the form of a Zordon-y disembodied face
But here, it takes on a different form to each Kree; whomever they most admire.
For Vers it's Annet Bening (Mar-Vell), as a way for her subconscious try to help her unlock the truth of her past
But this could also be a manipulation by
the Supreme Intelligence
Perhaps as a way to further confuse Vers about Annet Bening showing up in her dreams
Like if you have sex dreams about your teacher
You would probably assume it's a weird coincidence
of someone you see all the time slipping
into your subconscious.
And not that your teacher really was someone
you slept with in the past that you just blocked out.
By the way, nice.
*South Park "Nice" montage*
In the comics, the Supreme Intelligence is
cruelly manipulative, just like this
And actually turns out to have orchestrated
a self-genocide on the Kree race
To force the survivors to evolve
and break out of their genetic stagnation
Not very nice.
The Supreme Intelligence assigns Vers to the Star Force
Which is kind of like SEAL Team Six of the Kree military
They're led by Yon-Rogg.  They also include:
Korath (Djimon Hounsou)
Minn-Erva, Gemma Chan's character, she's a Kree geneticist in the comics
Att-Lass, Captain Atlus from the comics
played by Algenis Perez Soto
And Bron-Char! Played by Rune Temte
In the comics, Bron-Char wasn't really
a member of the Star force,
but his claim to fame was he was a Kree soldier who broke one of Captain America's shields
Also notice how the production designers of this movie use the same sets and backdrops of Hala
that we saw behind the Kree delegate in
Guardians of the Galaxy.
Great consistency.
And when the Star Force ships depart Hala,
they pass through these hexagonal wormholes
This is also a production design detail from the Guardians movies
In Volume 2, Rocket, Groot, Yondu and Kraglin
used the same intergalactic travel technology
The mission is the extraction of a spy
from the planet Torfa
It's a location also from the comics.
Actually a Skrull refugee planet
Hinting that these Skrull that they find are
actually refugees, not hostile invaders.
Also, Torfa is known for a toxic atmosphere caused by vibranium.
Suggesting that this planet could have been formed by the same astronomical event
that caused that vibranium meteorite
that struck Wakanda on Earth.
During this mission we see how Vers' Kree suit
projects a mask over her face.
This looks a lot like the same technology
that Peter Quill uses for his mask.
And that whole spacesuit that they use in Volume 2.
They all got it from the Kree.
This mission of course ends up being a trap, for the Skrull to capture Vers and scrub her memories
The Skrull are led by Talos,
not the pronunciation I thought it was gonna be,
played by Ben Mendelsohn.
Now, in the comics he's known as Talos the Untamed
He's got a fierce reputation, a Skrull warrior
But that changes when he gets captured by the Kree
and refuses to commit their whole ritualistic suicide where they shift into the face of their captor
And this all earns him the name 'Talos the Tamed'
Burn.
Similarly in this movie,
Talos does work with some of the Kree
But really the Skrull, as we see them in this movie,
have been changed drastically
from what we know from comics.
Vers relives her memories as Carol Danvers,
U.S. Air Force pilot
Alongside her friend maria Rambeau (Lashana Lynch)
Notice how Maria's call sign is "Photon"
That's a nod to her daughter, Monica Rambeau
Who grows up to become the Marvel hero Photon;
a.k.a. Pulsar
She also takes on the mantle of
Captain Marvel at one point
She's a major figure in the New Avengers
and perhaps a hero in the future Avengers films
If you look closely, one of the memories
features her stargazing with young Monica
as a shooting star zips across the night sky
And this brings up an interesting question
about the whole timeline of this movie
The main events are set in 1995
6 years after Carol left Earth in 1989
If Carol and Monica are seeing this shooting star,
say a year before she went missing
This could actually be Yondu's ship,
when he kidnapped a young Peter Quill
That was in 1988
And that is in Missouri, which isn't that far from Louisiana where the Rambeau home is
Carol calls Monica "Lieutenant Trouble",
which is also from the comics.
It's a nickname given to Kit Renner
Who's a huge fan of Captain Marvel,
who like Monica in this movie
helps Carol recover her memories after amnesia
Now the target memory for Talos features
Dr. Wendy Lawson, the Earth alias of Mar-Vell
The project she works on is Pegasus,
which should sound familiar to you
Pegasus is the operation initiated by
the World Security Council
tasked with researching and weaponising the Tesseract
We actually saw the end of the Pegasus project
at the beginning of the Avengers movie
and Tony Stark mentioned it in Iron Man 2
"I need some stuff out of storage."
"Get me everything from projects
Pegasus, Exodus and Goliath."
Lawson appears to work for
an early incarnation of Pegasus
A joint operation between
the U.S. Air Force and NASA
Before it became a S.H.I.E.L.D. operation
Where, in the comics at least,
it was an acronym that stood for:
Potential Energy Group/Alternate Source/United States
Mouthful.
Breaking free from her memory scrub,
Vers takes an escape pod to the planet's surface
Which turns out to be C-53,
a.k.a. Erf *derp face*
Now, the listed co-ordinates for Earth,
like all of the co-ordinates in this movie,
appear to be just random numbers and letters
But as we learned during our Easter egg hunts
in the Guardians movies
These co-ordinates might be code for something.
All I could find was that E.R.D.E., Erde
is a German word for Earth
I dunno. Let me know if you find anything else
And now that she has returned to Erde, I'm just gonna call Vers "Carol"
Even though she doesn't yet remember
that her name is Carol
It's just because I think "Vers" sounds really stupid.
CAROL crash lands in a Blockbuster Video
That's the first of many 90s references in
Captain Marvel
And this didn't rebrand its name to just "Blockbuster" until 1996, which is the year after this movie takes place
The movie titles visible around this Blockbuster include:
Last Action Hero
and a standy for True Lies
The directors for this movie,
Anna Boden and Ryan Fleck
said that 90s action movies like these
were big influences
Other influences included action movies like:
Total Recall
Independence Day
Men in Black
Now, the movie title that she picks up is The Right Stuff
And that is actually a book and a film about air force pilots who train to be the first NASA astronauts
Similar to Carol's function as an air force pilot,
working on a joint mission with NASA
Outside Carol talks to this security guard in a parking-lot
She asks if he's in charge of security for this district
And says sort of, the movie theatre has its own guy
Now there's actually a great inside joke
that goes along with this, but before I get to that
**Really long sponsor segment**
OK. Back to the security guard.
This is actually a cameo by Barry Curtis
The director of on-set security for all of the Marvel films
This guy's responsible for
preventing leaks on Marvel's end
But as he says here, not responsible security in movie theatres themselves
By the way, this I think, is the Barry that
Mark Ruffalo was worried about pissing off
When he spoiled the ending of Infinity War
"Wait 'til you see this next one. Everybody dies."
"Dude!"
"Is Barry gonna be mad at me?"
Ah, I love that clip
Carol also mentions having a universal translator
Which is another nod to the
Guardians of the Galaxy movies
In which James Gunn established that all the alien races in this universe communicate via universal translators
As Carol uses parts from a RadioShack GameBoy to rig up a way to communicate with the Star Force
The wall behind her is covered in posters
Including some 90s "Rock the Vote" signs
And a poster for The Smashing Pumpkins 1995 album "Mellon Collie and the Infinite Sadness"
This could be a nod to Brie Larson's past role as
Envy Adams in Scott Pilgrim vs. The World
Which was adapted from the comics
in which her character debuted in an issue titled
"The Infinite Sadness"
Next arrives the other Marvel heroes
who get their origins in this movie:
S.H.I.E.L.D. agents Nick Fury and Phil Coulson
With Samuel L. Jackson and Clark Gregg
Digitally de-aged for their roles
Marvel's using the same process that they used on
Robert Downy Jr in Civil War
Michael Douglas, Michelle Pfeiffer and Laurence Fishburne in the Ant-Man movies
And Kurt Russell in Guardians of the Galaxy Volume 2
But here the VFX artists had to keep this up
for the whole movie
Not just limited parts of it
Jackson wore a wig and motion trackers on his face
But the guy was nearly 70 and they de-aged him so well
Ad for the more action heavy shots
The production actually swapped in
stunt actor Kiante Elam
who actually played
one of the extremist soldiers in Iron Man 3
This leads to a chase through
the street and metro lines of L.A.
Which the directors based on the famous sequence in The French Connection
In which, Gene Hackman chased down a train car
from the street level below
The moment where Carol searches
through the train car for her target
Is a recreation of Hackman's search in that movie
Sitting in this car is, of course, Stan Lee
Making his traditional cameo
He's reading the script for the Kevin Smith movie "Mallrats"
Which he would make one of his first ever cameos in later in 1995
That's why he's actually credited as Stan Lee
in the credits of this movie
And he rehearses the line
*Stan impression* "Trust me true believer"
Which is actually what he tells Jason Lee in Mallrats
*Genuine Stan* "Trust me true believer"
Kevin Smith said that when he saw this while he was watching Captain Marvel it brought him to tears
Now, this fight between Carol and the old lady Skrull
is one of the highlights of the movie
Carol knows that she's a Skrull because, of course,
she passed by the real old lady earlier on the platform
And this fight is vicious!
I love how you can see the woman's glasses
flying off her face when she gets punched
And the directors said they included a take where her dentures flew out when her head hit the pole
Actually, these flips and kicks are performed
on an actual moving train car by stunt performers
They're sisters, Renae and Heidi Moneymaker
The directors also just did a really good job
Pacing this fight between quick paced action and pauses for character reactions
Resulting in this intense growl from the Skrull
in the middle of the fight
And when the other passengers hold Carol back
Notice how the man behind her in a suit,
kinda looks different between takes
That's because in the earlier shot this was an extra
But in the close up
the guy who gets hit is a different actor
actually the movie's fight coordinator, Walter Garcia
He had to dress up like the original extra
when they reshot this scene
so they could add this little moment
When Carol gets off the train,
she passes this red-haired woman with glasses
This is a cameo by the Captain Marvel comic writer
I mentioned earlier, Kelly Sue DeConnick
The one responsible for
this whole incarnation of the character
As the Skrull who posed as Coulson
undergoes the autopsy
The S.H.I.E.L.D. medical officer
is played by actor Nelson Franklin
Who appeared in Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
as agent Steve Wilson of the ATCU
An entity that deals with Inhumans,
though I don't think it's the same character here
Carol steals a motorcycle and gets
a new change of clothes from that mannequin
I actually think an earlier version of this scene
had her steal the guy's clothes too
In what might have been a reference to The Terminator
Underneath the jacket she wears
this Nine Inch Nails t-shirt. A nod to the 90s band
And the directors actually had to get special permission from Trent Reznor to feature this shirt
Carol meets Fury at the Poncho bar
And Poncho's is actually the name of a bar
mentioned in The Right Stuff
Near Edwards Air Force Base in California
where Air Force pilots would go hangout
The film's production put this Poncho's sign
over a different restaurant
The Zebra Lounge, which is also located in this area
Poncho's has a bunch of photos
of airplanes on the walls
And some of you asked in one of these is the Valkyrie, the Hydra bomber
That Captain America flew at the end of his movie
It's actually a Northrop YB-49 bomber
that was commissioned after World War II
And, yeah, it would be a little weird for this Air Force bar to have Hydra bombers on the wall
Carol and Fury get to know each other
And he says that before working for S.H.I.E.L.D.
he was a cold war era spy
Who worked in Belfast
Bukareszt
Belgrade
Budapest
He likes the Bs
And we actually learn another
B-named Fury outpost in Winter Soldier
When Cap' meets secretary Pierce
"That photo was taken 5 years after Nick and I met"
"When I was at state department in Bogotá"
Also it's interesting that Fury brought up Budapest
Because Marvel fans know, this could be a nod to another famous mission in Budapest
Referenced by Hawkeye and Black Widow in
The Avengers
"Just like Budapest all over again"
"You and I remember Budapest very differently"
Though, given the age difference here
Fury's Budapest mission was probably way earlier than whatever mission Clint and Natasha were a part of
Hopefully we'll see whole Budapest backstory
in Black Widow's upcoming solo film
Which is rumoured to take place
a few years before Iron Man in 2008
To prove he's not a Skrull, Fury tells Carol
that he can't eat toast if it's cut diagonally
I love this detail, because if you look closely
at a specific shot in Age of Ultron
When Fury's with the Avengers on the Barton farm
He's cutting bread and some of you said
that it looked like it was being cut diagonally
But no! When he picks up the bread,
it's definitely cut down the middle
Not diagonally.
Fury takes Carol to the Pegasus base in the desert
And he confirms that his full name is
Nicholas Joseph Fury, which is the case in the comics.
Also, if you look closely at his badge,
it lists them as level 03
Now, that's pretty low for S.H.I.E.L.D. agents,
last time Fury was a part of S.H.I.E.L.D. he was level 10
So putting him at level 03 here
means that Fury wouldn't have
the same security clearance
to know everything what's going on with Pegasus
and what Dr. Lawson's research was all about
Now, it's not clear if this Pegasus base is the exact same one that we saw at the beginning of The Avengers
But, both are located in the Mojave Desert in California
But if you look at the terrain surrounding the whole
joint dark energy mission facility, it's a lot flatter
Whereas this is more rugged
Fury and Carol explore the records archives
and they run into Goose the cat
In the earlier memory, it was established that
he was a pet of Mar-Vell
And I guess he's still roaming this facility
6 years after she's gone
Now, in the comics, Carol Danvers' cat is named "Chewie"
Like the Wookie and brands of oatmeal bars
But here they named him Goose
after the character in Top Gun
In both instances, this cat is actually a Flerken
An alien species that resembles and Earth cat
They have tentacles in their mouths
They're able to swallow large quantities
In the comics, it's Rocket who outs the Flerken
and freaks out
Here, later on in this movie, it's Talos
Carol looks through Lawson's records and plans
for a light-speed engine
And realises from her notes that she was a Kree
And the movie actually teases a final reveal here
If you look at the old photograph of Carol
You can almost make out that her call sign,
on the side of her jet, says "Avenger"
Talos arrives
And the fact that he calls Fury "Nicholas"
tips off Fury that he's a shapeshifter
Leading to this whole fight
Now, there's an odd detail during this
In the scuffle, Fury defensively
unloads the clip from Talos' gun
But when he gets a hold of the gun later
he pulls the trigger on it
Now, I was thinking maybe Fury thought
one bullet could have been left in the chamber
But the directors acknowledge that Fury
just did this in the heat of the moment
Which is also probably why
Fury angrily throws the gun at him
Fury's saved when Carol
hits Talos with her photon blasts
Now listen closely to the sound design here
*sound with deep, rumbling thunder*
You can kinda hear a rumble of thunder
and overall it sounds a lot more organic
compared to the sound of Iron Man's repulsors
*high whining charge followed by a deep "pew"*
The directors wanted photon blasts
to sound more organic, more natural
Coming from within Carol's body
As opposed to the precise, mechanical,
defibrillator charge sound that Tony Stark's armour has
Carol and Fury escape in this jet
Which is a predecessor to the Quinjet
that S.H.I.E.L.D. will use later on
This is a fourth generation called the Quadjet
I look forward to the sixth generation model
The Sexjet
They arrive in Louisianna
where Carol reunites with Maria and Monica Rambeau
Talos surprises them
But if you look closely
The cup he's sipping from is the same design pattern
on the Big Kahuna Burger cup
That Jackson sips in Pulp Fiction
Talos says he stands before them as his true self
Whereas in the scene before with Ben Mendelsohn's actual appearance, that was an imposter
Now, notice how Mendelsohn in his Skrull form
speaks with his natural Australian accent
Whereas the human used his American accent
So now this is, in a way, his true form
Talos helps Carol understand the truth
With a black-box recording proving that Yon-Rogg
and the Kree Star Force were the ones
who shot down Carol and Mar-Vell
They pull this up from an old-school desktop CD-ROM that takes forever to load
Part of the movie's running joke of 90s computer tech
Like earlier we saw the AltaVista internet search engine
Carol finally recalls the origin of her powers
An explosion from Kree tech;
a light-speed engine built by Mar-Vell
Now, this is similar to Carol's origin in the comics
With the death of Mar-Vell
and an explosion leading to her powers
But the twist here is that the Skrull aren't the evil empire that the Kree propaganda suggested
They're actually refugees whom Mar-Vell was trying to help find a new home world
away from the Kree.
Using a light-speed engine
Carol was brainwashed by Yon-Rogg
using Kree blood transfusin and memory wipes
Now this is actually the same process that Nick Fury will later use to revive Coulson in Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
After his death in Avengers
Kree blood
Memory wipe
Perhaps Fury learned this process was possible from what ahppened with Carol Danvers
Carol works with Monica to help decide on
a new colour scheme for her suit
Now that she no longer aligns herself with the Kree
One of the options is red and yellow
Which Monica says "no" to
Perhaps because this is a colour scheme
of the other "Captain Marvel", Shazam
Another option is green and white
Which is actually the colour scheme of
the original Mar-Vell's Kree armour in the comics
And they head off to Mar-Vell's space lab
cloaked in orbit around Earth
Here they find the energy core that powered Mar-Vell's original light-speed machine
TA-DA!
The Tesseract
a.k.a. the Space Stone
One of the Infinity Stones
It, of course, has the power to open rifts in space and transport you anywhere in the universe
Its existence here is interesting
Because in the Marvel timeline
The last known appearance of the Tesseract was when Howard Stark recovered it from the ocean floor
At the end of Captain America
He presumably studied it for years thereafter
But now this movie is suggesting that it ended up in the hands of Dr. Lawson, a.k.a. Mar-Vell
I'll actually dig deeper into this whole Tesseract timeline in another video I'm working on
One interesting thing to note here
is that if the Tesseract powered the light-speed engine
that exploded and gave Carol her powers
You could argue that carol's powers
came from the Space Stone itself
In Infinity War, we learn that because Scarlet Witch's powers were derived from an Infinity Stone
She could destroy said Infinity Stone
So perhaps this means that Captain Marvel
could also destroy Stones
Potentially giving her a unique advantage in Endgame
This lab is littered with 90s era toys
because it contains hidden Skrull refugees and children
One of these toys is a Happy Days "Fonz" lunch box
That's what they used to store the Tesseract
But you can also see these troll dolls
Now, in the past I've speculated over
another possible link
between Guardians of the Galaxy and Captain Marvel
A throwaway line from Peter Quill about
a Kree girl he hooked up with
"Right here a Kree girl tried to rip out my thorax"
Now, we don't know where Captain Marvel's
heading off to in this ship at the end of the movie
Or where in the Galaxy she travelled
throughout the mid-90s and 2018
when she meets the Avengers in that post-credit scene
But we do know that Peter Quill hooked up with
some very aggressive Kree girl
or a human Earth girl who he thinks is Kree
And we know that Quill had at least one troll doll, because he used one to troll Yondu
So maybe a Captain Marvel sequel or a
Guardians of the Galaxy prequel
could show this whole fling
In this scene we can also see a Space Invaders pinball machine
but notice how the props department changed the art on the back of it
Perhaps because the original pinball machine
of Space Invaders
essentially stole the design of the Alien Xenomorph
The Kree arrive and for Carol back into stasis
with the Supreme Intelligence
But Carol breaks out by overpowering her inhibitor chip
And she gives off this golden glow
She's super charged
In the comics, this is called "going binary"
Because Captain Marvel gets her power
from the energy of a white hole
The theoretical opposite of a black hole
In which infinite amounts of matter and energy
beam out of it
Carol blows back the other Kree
She tells Fury to "Take the Tesseract. Leave the lunch box."
A nod to the Godfather quote
"Leave the gun. Take the cannoli."
Fury doesn't want to touch it, so Goose swallows it!
Awesome!
This actually echoes a joke by
Bruce banner in The Avengers
"What does Fury want me to do? Swallow it?"
Uh-Oh, Ruffo spoiling future events again.
Somebody call Barry
As Carol goes full binary
Wipes out the Kree warships
Including the bombing raid by Ronan
Fury and Maria return to Earth
And as Fury takes Goose he tells the Flerken
"I'm trusting you not to eat me"
Now if you've been watching my videos
in recent months
You'll know that I gave a loud "HA!" to that line
Specifically the word "trust"
Yeah, roll the clip
"Last time I trusted someone, I lost an eye"
Fury trusted Goose who then
scratched his eye out
One of the few predictions I made for a movie
that, shockingly, came true
It also confirms why the wound over Fury's eye
was in the shape of a scratch from a cat paw
Fury shouts "Mother Flerken!"
because it's Sam Jackson
He's gotta work in a "Mother *beep*" in there
It's also a nod to the way "Flerken"
is used as a profanity in the comics
Like when Carol says "no one steals my Flerken cat!"
After Carol destroys all of Ronan's bombs
She stares him down from space
and he promises to return for her
So that explains why we don't see him become
the whole rogue extremist
that he is in Guardians yet in this movie
Presumably there's more story to tell with him
in a future Captain Marvel film
Back on Earth
Maria and Fury escape the pursuing Kree ship
through a canyon
It's very evocative of the Captain Hiller
dog fight in Independence Day
And when Carol confronts Yon-Rogg in the desert,
she drags him back to his ship
Similar to how Hiller "welcome to Earth" 's the alien
and drags him across the desert
As they wind down back at the Rambeau house
Fury tells Carol to go by a new name
And although the words "Captain Marvel"
is never said out loud in this movie
Fury does give her the inspiration by singing
the Marvelettes "Please Mr. Postman"
Now you may know this song from the Vine meme
*Memeing it up*
This would be the second time in recent memory a Marvel origin movie referenced a Vine meme
After Shuri's "What are those?" line in Black Panther
*Reference meme*
Also Carol returns Fury's pager
Which she confiscated earlier after he used it to call her into Talos
She spruced it up to boost its signal across galaxies
Setting up the post-credit scene in Infinity War
and in this movie
Check out my other video for more details that
you might have missed in the post-credit scene
And that brings us to the final scene in Nick Fury's office
Coulson brings Fury various options for a prosthetic eye to replace the one that Goose scratched out
But Fury prefers his eye patch
Most likely because he likes this whole bad ass myth narrative that he lost it during a Kree interrogation
But there could be another reason
Like Fury now knows that Skrull shapeshifters exist in this universe
The ones that he met were relatively friendly
But there may be others out there
with more nefarious goals
This scratched eye is one unique marker on Nick Fury
If he keeps it covered with the patch
There's no way any Skrull could know, from sight alone, what his eye wound look like
So if S.H.I.E.L.D. were compromised in the future
And a Skrull tried to copy Nick Fury, all the real Nick Fury would have to do is lift his eye patch
As a way to prove that he is the real one
The final detail dovetails this movie
directly into The Avengers saga
Fury's writing up his proposal for
"The Protector Initiative"
His and Coulson's idea to find other heroes
like Captain Marvel out there to protect Earth
But upon seeing her call sign in her old photo "Avenger"
He re-names this initiative
If you listen closely to the music, you can hear
Alan Silvestri's iconic march of The Avengers' theme
But to be honest, we never do see what he writes
Could have been anything
The Flerken Initiative
Who knows
But I'm curious to know from you guys
Which spinoff story would you like to see next?
Captain Marvel vs the whole Kree and
the Supreme Intelligence and Hala?
Or maybe a prequel with
Carol and the Guardians of the Galaxy?
Or a new Skrull secret invasion storyline?
With some other, more evil, terror cell
And if secret invasion
Which Marvel hero do you want to be established as a Skrull in disguise all this time?
And why is it Hawkeye? Let the guy live in peace.
Comment down below with your thoughts
Follow me on Twitter and Instagram @EAVoss
Subscribe to this channel New Rockstars on YouTube
and subscribe to our podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
If you live in the L.A. area check out my live comedy show darkest timeline every first Friday of the month
Thanks for watching mother Flerkens!
*roll credits*
Eric starts a lot of sentences with "Now" and "Actually".
*Thanks to IMDB, Wikipedia and the MCU Wikia for helping with spelling actors' names, place names*
*and weird comic stuff*